c'est pour ce moment là qu'ils ont fait
un voyage de 2700 km les mariniers
polonais la grande parade qui les met à
l'honneur
à cet instant-là voir leur appartient
ils se sentent comme chez eux et ce
n'est pas étonnant puisque à les croire
rien ne ressemble plus à la loire que la
vistule le plus grand fleuve polonais
c'est comme deux soeurs
c'est le même courant le même sable le
même paysage
ce sont ici comme à la maison ici la
loire est plus forte que la vistule il
ya beaucoup d'endroits identique on
emmenait des amis français sur la
vistule et nous on dit c'est comme la
loi en d'avis si ou lé in die zeit qu
ils soient les bateaux polonais sont
donc logiquement assez proche de ce
qu'on a l'habitude de voir en loire avec
quelques particularités culturelles tout
de même parmi la dizaine d'embarcations
qu'on peut voir ici deux ont fait le
voyage depuis la pologne par voies
navigables tandis que les autres sont
venus par camion comment loire leurs
propriétaires ne sont pas des marins
professionnels mais des passionnés qui
essaye de faire vivre ou revivre la
tradition s'était complètement oublié
les bateaux en bois ont disparu il ya
plus de 30 ans sur la ville située en
fait toute la circulation suivi à la
distance
il n'y a plus de bateaux parce que la
navigation est difficile la vistule
était vie jusqu'à ce qu'on s'y remette
construit des bateaux en bois qu'on a
créé des petits croisière de trois jours
entre les villes
et puisque les polonais font tout comme
nous
et réciproquement ils ont aussi leurs
chants de marins illustration avec le
groupe
banana boat qui se produit tous les
jours sur les quais depuis le début du
festival
ja